-Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Enjoy yourself.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
Happy Halloween!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love Halloween.
It's that special day
that we tell our kids
to eat tons of sugar,
knock on strangers' doors,
and lie about who they are.
It's just --
[ Laughter ]
It's just good parenting,
really.
Yep.
Halloween is a magical night
where we all pretend
to be someone we're not,
or as it's also known,
posting on Instagram.
And Halloween is interesting
because it turns every family
into the Mafia.
Kids come home with candy and
have to kick up 10% to the boss.
It's like, "All right.
A fun-size Snickers, all right?
Just wet my beak."
'Course, a lot of people
have the same costume idea.
It'll look less like Halloween
and more like the running
of the Barbies today.
[ Laughter ]
I read that some towns
have laws
that ban older kids
from trick-or-treating.
-Aww.
[ Audience groans ]
I get a little skeptical
when a kid's like,
[ Imitates smoking, deep voice ]
No, Tootsie Rolls.
They're hell on my bridge work.
Tough on my bridge."
[ Normal voice ] Speaking of
candy, I saw a poll
that said 51% of people say
Reese's Peanut Butter Cups
are the best Halloween candy.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
They actually released
a lot of interesting data
about the holiday.
Check this out.
First up, when asked,
"What are your plans
for trick-or-treating?
30% of people
said, "Getting dressed up,"
20% said, "Handing out candy,"
50% said, "Turning off
all the lights in my house
and watching an iPad
under a thick blanket."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ding-dong!
-"Lower the volume,
lower the volume,
lower the volume!"
[ Laughter ]
Here's another one.
When asked, "What's a quote
that strikes fear
into your heart?"
60% said, "I see dead people."
30% said, "Whatever you do,
don't fall asleep."
10% said, "We have information
about your car's
extended warranty."
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Up next, when asked,
"How old is too old
to go trick-or-treating?"
40% said, "14 years old."
Interesting.
40% said, "16 years old."
20% said, "If you know the sound
AOL used to make
when you logged on."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Bee ckkkk!
Be-yoo!
-You've got mail.
-Oh, cool!
[ Laughter ]
Next one asks, "What's the best
couples costume?"
25% said, "Taylor and Travis."
[ Cheers and applause ]
25% said, "Tatum and Kravitz,"
[ Laughter ]
50% said,
"Boebert and Grab-It's."
Hey, wait, wait, wait.
-Ayy!
-What?
-What?!
♪♪
Grab it.
-Finally, when asked,
"what's the next closest thing
to a haunted house?"
20% said,
"Spirit Halloween tomorrow."
[ Laughter ]
30% said, "Rite Aid today,"
and 50% said, "Mike Pence's
campaign headquarters
next week."
[ Laughter ]
Very important.
Interesting poll.
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well, this is fun.
Last night at the White House,
President Biden
and the First lady
handed out books and candy
to trick-or-treaters.
Books.
[ Laughter ]
Some kids are like,
"I got a Twix,"
while others are like,
"I got '50 Shades of Grey.'
What?
What's going on?"
You guys see this?
Yesterday, Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis
denied rumors that he's been
wearing lifts in his boots
to make himself taller.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Maybe that's
why he hates Disney.
They won't let him ride
any of the rides.
[ Laughter ]
"Can't.
Nothing we can..."
[ Cheers and applause ]
DeSantis claims that he's 5'11",
which is a lie
because if he were actually
5'11", he'd say he's 6'.
[ Laughter ]
Some business news -- Walmart
just unveiled over 100 stores
that they revamped
and modernized.
Yeah, it's impressive.
They went from this...
to this.
Yeah, unbelievable.
Amazing.
[ Laughter ]
Amazing. Yeah.
Some more business news.
The C.E.O. of BlackBerry
is stepping down.
Yeah, he knew it was time to go
when they went out of business
five years ago.
[ Laughter ]
I read that deputies
in North Carolina
had to rescue three bears that
got stuck in a locked minivan.
Yep, a locked minivan.
They tried three crowbars
to open the door.
One was too long,
one was too short,
and one was just right.
-Thank you.
[ Rimshot ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We did it!
-Three bears.
-Come on.
-Well, get this.
I heard about a museum
in Barcelona
that welcomed nudist visitors
for a tour of Greek statues.
[ Laughter ]
Or as my friend,
who just got back from Barcelona
calls them, "Nudiths."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on!
-I think that --
[ Rimshot ]
You got that?
Well, guys,
it's the last day of October,
so I thought it'd be nice
to give a little recap
of the entire month.
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ October is over, so ♪
♪ Ten months down
and two to go ♪
♪ We're all focused
on one person ♪
♪ She made... ♪
-"1989 (Taylor's Version)"
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Congress couldn't
find a speaker ♪
♪ Our country
was down a leader ♪
♪ Tempers, they began to flare
like ♪
-Subject to the call
of the chair.
[ Gavel bangs loudly ]
[ Laughter ]
-♪ "Golden Bachelor" is great ♪
♪ Love to watch him
go on dates ♪
♪ But the women
sometimes fight ♪
♪ And Gary
cannot drive at night ♪
[ Truck horn honks ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ We saw "Saw" and "Exorcist" ♪
♪ "Five Nights at Freddy's"
was legit ♪
♪ There was so much stuff
to scare us ♪
♪ But not as bad as... ♪
-A bedbug infestation in Paris.
-♪ Trump spent every day
in court ♪
♪ Mike Pence
cut his campaign short ♪
♪ The whole thing
was kind of strange ♪
♪ Just like ♪
-"The Star Spangled Banner,"
performed tonight
by Flavor Flav.
[ Laughter ]
-♪ iPhone 15 overheats ♪
♪ Keeps you warm
for trick-or-treat ♪
♪ We dress up for Halloween ♪
♪ I'll go as ♪
-The Kevin James meme.
[ Laughter ]
-♪ Another month
has come and gone ♪
♪ Leaves are falling
on your lawn ♪
♪ November will be better,
surely ♪
♪ Unless you are
a freakin' turkey ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'll play this one day.
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
Finally, everybody,
it is Tuesday.
It is time for "WePost."
Here we go.
-♪ WePost ♪
♪♪
♪ WePost ♪
-Welcome to "WePost"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is where we,
as a group, decide something
that we should post on socials.
I'm going to show you
five different posts,
and we're all going to vote
on whether you like
each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
There's green for yes,
red for no.
You can vote for all of them.
You can vote for none of them.
Whatever you want. We're going
to see the results live.
Higgins, Roots,
you have your clickers, too?
-Ready.
-Yep. Tariq, are you
in a positive mood this evening?
-I mean, it depends.
Like, once you start reading
them posts, then we'll see.
-Yeah.
Okay, here we go.
Tonight, I will post whichever
one gets the most likes
from all of us
because it's not a MePost.
No, no, no, it is a WePost.
[ Crowd cheers ]
Alright. Ready?
The first post is...
[ Light laughter ]
I'll just do --
Eh, I'll go -- I'll lift it up.
Let me go all the way
underneath.
Alright, here we go.
I think this one's going to be
a little bit better, though,
I don't know.
Let me see this one.
Alright. Hey, that's not bad.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-There you go.
-I don't know
if we're in posting levels yet,
but that one's better than --
-That one's better than
the last one.
-Yeah.
-Twice as much.
-Tariq is just not
speaking at all.
He's just lost.
-I mean, here's the thing.
Respectfully,
I haven't cared for one yet.
[ Laughter ]
-When you said "respectfully"
and then insulted me,
what -- did you want me to --
-I wanted to take the edge off.
[ Laughter ]
-It worked. It worked.
I kind of thought
that was respectful. Thanks.
This next one here says...
[ Laughter ]
A little dippity doo.
-[ Squelching ]
-Alright, let's see
the results here.
Hair in the '90s?
Hey, not bad!
Now we're talking!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now we're talking.
Now I'm seeing something.
Tariq's got a little --
He's got a little smile.
-Been like a ladder.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-This one's a little better.
-Yeah, I think this next one
might be the one.
-Really?
-Yeah. I have a feeling.
I could see it right now
on the cue cards,
and I think this might be it.
-Let's do it.
-Alright. Here we go.
It says...
[ Laughter ]
Just kind of sticks in there.
Just kind of stays in there
and you go, "Oh, yeah."
-Just love it.
-There you go.
That's my -- Out
of all the molasses candies,
all the molasses
chewable candies,
Bit-O-Honey is up there.
-It's definitely up there.
-Let's see the results here.
-Ooh!
-Wow.
-Alright, might be
the other one,
but I think it's going
to be this one.
-They said, "Thank you, no."
-This one,
I'm not only -- I'm saying
it's going to be this one,
but this one might even
get a standing ovation.
-Really? It's that good?
-I don't know if it's that good.
I just feel like the audience
wants to stand up.
-Little pap, yeah.
Seventh inning stretch.
-Maybe we could see --
It's made me laugh.
This made me laugh.
-This one made you laugh.
-It made me laugh in rehearsal.
And, yeah.
-Okay.
-So I think this is the one.
If I could take
all my votes back
and add it all to this,
I would do it.
I'm going to press it now
just in case.
-Oh, my gosh.
It's called the prequel.
-I don't know
if it even works right now.
-Yeah.
-But I'm going to do that
just in case they turn
the computers on now.
Alright. The last one says...
[ Laughter ]
Not bad, not bad.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
-I feel good about this.
-Sitting ovation.
-If we win, do we get
a standing ovation?
Let's see the results.
Booyah! Come on, get up!
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Oh!
Guys, you nailed it.
Looks like the winner
is mannequin right there.
I'm going to post this
during the break.
If you happen to see it online,
give that WePost a repost.
We have a great show.